hi I'm Natalie Portman and I'm here to
answer your questions while playing with
puppies my cuties I'm really proud of my
kids they're really incredible in terms
of work I'm proudest of directing my
phone until 11:00 darkness and adapting
it
I would love to direct another film I
don't have a particular plan it's kind
of in the creative phase of figuring
that out but yes I would love to direct
again and they will it's a good question
maybe V for Vendetta in a buddy cop
movie TIFF Haddish maybe
the thing I'd want people don't come
away from eating animals seeing is that
factory farming is really like the the
vast majority of the way that our food
is raised and it's not good for our
planet it's not good for humans and it's
certainly not good for the animals so
looking for new ways of feeding
ourselves that doesn't have to destroy
living creatures and our planet for
screenwriters to really work on every
character having their own voice I think
sometimes you definitely see the
screenwriters voice in there but you
don't always see that the characters
have different voices themselves actors
um experience life because you want to
be painting from real experience not
from like watching other movies or TV
shows or something so it's important to
have a lot of life experience go out
live try things well read Black Swan
because of course I met my husband there
so I would relive that any day dinner
with my family
wine definitely wine yeah I'm red yes oh
so many so many I have many friends who
I'd like to work with like America
Ferrera and I sort of worked with
rashida Jones Julianne Moore Cate
Blanchett Isabella pair there's a lot I
kind of want to work with actresses in
general we rarely get to work together
[Music]
sure but my character did die so it
would take some narrative narrative
creativity for sure well you need to get
a little cheating point
well definitely the Padme outfits were
more comfortable the queen outfits had
some heavy head wear that was very
beautiful very beautiful constructed but
not as comfortable one strange Rock the
National Geographic show I'd really like
to travel and Southeast Asia like
Cambodia allows like backpack through
their Bhutan you are something this is
how you like yes these dogs are off from
the Vanderpump Rescue Foundation you can
learn more about how do I got them at
Vanderpump dogs org I'm gonna take these
all home you know that's your present to
me right
[Music]